[Music]
season three finale of Riverdale left
fans with more questions and answers we
now know who the real gargoyle king is
but it appears that the core for now
have bigger fish to fry watch until the
very end to find out why Archie Veronica
Jughead and Betty are going to have the
worst senior year spring break of all
time season 3 spoilers are coming your
way so don't say we didn't warn you the
hunt is afoot survive the night was
jam-packed with some shocking
revelations Edgar ever never is running
an organ harvesting front Romani Lodge
is going to jail for attempting to
murder Hyrum the farm has ascended and
everyone is missing with the exception
of Kevin who's totally bummed about
being left behind fpn Alice's son
Charles is very much alive he's an FBI
agent who's been trying to build a case
against Edgar and the farm and Alice is
working with her son as an undercover
agent but that's just a fraction of the
tea that was filled we also found out
that a redheaded chick was posing as The
Gargoyle King and pretending to be Jason
while Penelope blossom pulled his
strings
the real gargoyle King is Penelope and
she's more than a little insane she
wants revenge on the town that has taken
everything from her Penelope and Hal
Cooper were working together that is
until she shot and killed him out of the
blue the core four survived Penelope's
games against all odds thanks to Tony
Sherrill and the Serpent's and the
pretty poisons but the most shocking
revelation of all has to do with Spring
Break and Jughead Jones so now that
we're all caught up let's find out what
season four has in store for us
[Music]
ever since Hyrum found out that Hermione
and Veronica double-crossed him and got
him arrested he's been scheming to even
out the score getting Hermione arrested
was easy after all she did try to murder
him not too long ago but it seems like
Hyrum has bigger plans for Veronica
and according to him she has no idea
what's coming for her this is a pretty
bold statement and since Hyrum is in
jail his plan probably has to do with
inmates shockingly Hyrum was sent to his
very own prison where he has some pretty
major influence and it appears as though
chick was also sent to Hiram's
penitentiary it's safe to say that Hyrum
is going to hit Veronica where it hurts
right in the wallet seconds before
Hermione was arrested she was speaking
to someone on the phone and said how
could this so we can definitely expect
to find out about Hyrum secret in season
4 could Hyrum owe people money or be
running a drug front that could
potentially land Veronica and jail
whatever the case may be we don't
foresee Hyrum staying in jail for too
long he might siege a prison break and
SiC some of Riverdale's finest criminals
on Veronica and her friends while making
his great escape surprise surprise Edgar
ever never isn't the peaceful guru he's
been pretending to be the farmer is a
front
Kevin fangs by the time buddy in the
ganga rive at the sisters of quiet mercy
everyone is m.i.a except for kevin their
white clothes are left in heaps on the
floor giving the illusion that edgar and
his many wives spontaneously disappeared
but we know better than that
Alice helped Cheryl escape the sisters
of quiet Mercy through a tunnel that led
to Fox Forest
however this tunnel used to be bricked
up but according to Alice Edgar had it
reopened when he bought the compound
could this be how Edgar and the farm
managed to disappear without using the
front entrance
Edgar might be moving the farm to a new
town or selling off his followers one by
one whatever the case may be executive
producer Roberto aguirre-sacasa
confirmed during an interview with E W
that the missing people case would be
resolved early on in
season four chances are kevin was made
to stay back because his kidney had
already been taken out do you guys think
the farms inhabitants are going to wake
up in Fox forests with some missing
organs
yikes we sure hope not fans have been
curious to find out if chick was telling
Betty the truth when he confessed to
killing Charles and stealing his
identity well lo and behold chick is a
liar big shocker there Charles Smith is
an FBI agent who's been working with his
estranged mother Alice to catch edgar
ever never in the act he made his first
ever appearance at the end of the season
three finale and let's just say that his
mere existence makes things super
awkward for bug head and since barchi is
back together we can only expect that
bug head will call it quits in season
four but their separation probably won't
last for the entire season during the
same interview with E W Roberto revealed
that Charles has some secrets of his own
and that a good portion of season four
will circle around Betty and her serial
killer gene that he has been fighting
her dark side for a long time now and it
looks like she's about to breathe could
her dark side be what leads to jugheads
alleged death midway through season four
yeah we're not too sure about that
either but it's safe to say that the
poor four are going to have to cover up
a murder in the upcoming season oddly
enough Charles doesn't seem to be a
cause for concern after all Roberto also
told ET online that Charles and Betty
would go on to have a positive
relationship so could Betty murder
someone to protect Charles in a
desperate attempt to salvage what's left
of her family or is Roberto trying to
throw us off Charles's trail it wouldn't
be the first time Riverdale led us to
believe that Jughead Jones had kicked
the bucket so fans are pretty much
convinced that Jughead is alive and well
but why wasn't he around the bonfire and
why were his friends burning his beanie
well the only thing that makes sense to
us is that Jughead murdered someone and
is too injured to cover up his tracks so
his friends are taking care of the body
for him if some of the victims blood
landed on
hence beanie then it would make sense
that Archie Veronica and Betty would be
throwing it into the fire so who did the
gang murder and why are they so nervous
about getting caught this makes us think
that they killed a high-profile person
like Hiram or a member of the FBI like
Charles soo do you guys think Jughead is
going to meet an early demise midway
through season four or is the show's
narrator on the run for killing someone
in self-defense let us know what your
theories are in the comment section
below and that's all we have for you
today give this video a big thumbs up if
you're excited to find out what happens
to Jughead and be sure to subscribe to
the things for more videos about your
favorite series and movies thanks for
watching we'll see you soon
[Music]